choices maybe mr robot's right
that's what this is all about narration
may not seem like the strong
structural arch that holds a show
together but sometimes it does
just that and that was way too much a
television show's narrator is like the
audience's friend providing nuance
insight gossip and everything in between
sometimes the show's narrator becomes a
beloved voice or character that is so
instrumental to a series it just would
not be the same without them
the word george michael was searching
for was creepy
there are different narration types like
posthumous interactive
and nostalgic narrators the most common
is the inner monologue narrator
where the audience dives into the story
from the view of a particular
character's mindset
some examples include you mr robot
the mindy project sex and the city and
grey's anatomy these narrators are also
the main protagonists making them
interactive narrators because they
interact with the other characters in
the show
would you please stop narrating can't
help but danny each of these narrators
guide the series along with their
present tense first-person narration
the audience is able to see their
thought process which not only reflects
how that character interacts with other
characters
but how we the audience views them as
well it enables us to see the show
through the characters eyes which helps
makes a character seem
more real momentary narrators provide
narration and reference to specific
moments or instances
a life you save could be your own what
are we watching voiceovers are sprinkled
in
and demonstrate the characters frame of
mind for example
sex in the city carrie bradshaw narrated
her blog as she shared issues of career
dating friendships and love her
narration was profound because she
related to the show's demographic
and she became one of the first
television icons for female sexual
freedom
and indulgence his name was jake he was
everything i was looking for that night
themes of this were seen in the mindy
project from the perspective of a woman
of color
mindy related issues of a similar
message and normalized a hard-working
south asian woman that also liked dating
party or two met in an elevator my hair
came undone
are you kidding me i'm basically sandra
bullock these narrators felt like her
friends because they shared real world
issues and experiences
that we could also understand inner
monologue narrations are also popular in
you
mr robot and dexter in you
joe's narration adds to the show overall
eeriness it provides a glimpse into his
rationale for stalking creeping
and more
an accident his inner dialogue fills up
most of the show's screen time
noting just how loud joe's head is and
it's a stark contrast his seemingly
charming persona
the same can be said for dexter as
audiences are inside the mind of a
killer
i don't think they approve of what i
sometimes do to their masters
this mindset provides us with a unique
understanding of these complex
characters
and how they've evolved to develop into
their current state
this is also a stepping stone for some
audiences to empathize with the
protagonist deeply
we've all seen the twitter threads
reminding people of how joe is not the
hot boyfriend of their dreams
mr robot is different to the other shows
because instead of listening in on the
character's thoughts
ellie is speaking directly to us i know
i know taking more than i should i'm
breaking my rule but come on
in mr robot we are elliot's friends we
are directly involved in a story
submerged in his world he asks us for
his help
he lies to us and in turn the fourth
wall is shattered because the audience
becomes
a character in the story
unlike an inner monologue narration the
narrator all along is where we find out
that the narrator was one of the
characters we've been watching for the
entire series
much like us watching carrie's blog from
sex in the city
we get to see jane's telenovela unfold
in jane the virgin
before she opens it i will remind you
this is a telenovela the narrator and
jane the virgin is the glue that helps
make it a telenovela
our latin lover narrator explains
concludes and
gossips his way through the series and
becomes his own character
i mean more relevant than hoodwin in an
epic battle between batman and wolverine
in a series finale we find out that the
narrator is jane and rafael's son
mateo this ties the series together and
allows us to bond with matteo in a way
that differs from us witnessing him in
his early childhood years
she said i would be great at voiceover
work
and for the record i am in gossip girl
the blogger provided all the tea
about the wealthy upper east side it
crew throughout the series the voice was
an all-knowing mystery because their
identity was a secret
in the end it turned out to be one of
the show's main characters i'm one of
serena van der woodson's on-again
off-again bows dan humphrey hey upper
eastsiders
gossip girl here and i have the biggest
news ever the narration in gossip girl
was iconic not only for xoxo gossip girl
but also for changing gossip culture as
it moved from a print to digital medium
which was aided by the show's narration
the reveal of gossip girl was also a
change for both the characters and for
audiences
because the relationship with humphreys
altered after his reveal
other narration styles include the
classic storyteller like in riverdale
audiences watch jughead's book unfold
and he gives us a clear
picture of what it was like to be in
riverdale at that time
and you start seeing the shadows
underneath
the name of our town is riverdale he
shares his story from a future
perspective
and this makes him a nostalgic narrator
it also provides a little hope
that no matter how dire the situation
seems he makes it out to tell his tale
ted mosby from howard met your mother is
another notorious nostalgic narrator
he tells his kids about how he met the
mother through reflecting on his early
years
living in new york city with his four
best friends
my life was good and then uncle marshall
went and screwed the whole thing up
will you marry me mosby is an unreliable
narrator
because he indulges in character back
pedalling he forgets names and
storylines
all the time we all remember blabla the
goat
and the mysterious floating beer bottle
trick it was confirmed by the show's
creator greg thomas that this
narration style was done on purpose
because it added legitimacy
humor and authenticity to ted's
character
another narration style is a detached
observer
and so michael started to become relaxed
and a short time later his mother
arrived anything but
someone broke in again in arrested
development for example the narrator is
never revealed nor explicitly stated to
be connected to the bluth family
their dry sense of humor however helps
frame a scene and it definitely
punctuated the plotline's humor
other narrative styles include the
posthumous narrator who is a character
that has passed on
this is seen in 13 reasons why and if
you're listening to this tape
you're one of the reasons why in the
series hannah has died but continues to
narrate season one through her tapes
allowing for a more somber tone for the
series an additional narrative frame is
the opening and closing narration
in criminal minds there is no
traditional storytelling but instead a
quote at the end and beginning of each
episode
these quotes framed the show topically
and structurally
the aim was to contrast the show's
solemn tone and provide inspiration
or hope when you look long into an abyss
the abyss looks into you narrators
normally provide the storytelling
framework for a tv show
mr robot has become my god but they also
allow for us to connect with them
like a knowledgeable friend a series is
transformed becoming more realistic
through the narrator's thoughts
stories or explanations which cements
the need for a strong narrator
rebuilding the banana stand for a second
time hey can i give you a hand
so what other shows do you think would
not work without a narrator
let us know in the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe and hit the
bell icon to receive notifications
until next time thanks for watching